[Musik]
august hanning spricht von mehr als zwei
millionen überwiegend jungen männern
dieser 2015 eingewandert sind und die
nächste welle steht schon vor der tür
alice beide beziehen sich in ihrer rede
hier eines ganz besonderen stil mittels
frame nicht bemerkt das geht vielen so
gehen wir der sache mal etwas genauer
auf den grund
fremming kommt vom englischen wort frame
und das bedeutet rahmen frame soll
ausdrücken dass die wortwahl bei einem
bestimmten thema einen interpretations
rahmen vorgibt ein glas ist zum beispiel
halb voll oder halb leer
je nachdem wie wir betrachten die
informationen bleibt dieselbe
doch wirkt sie auf uns ganz
unterschiedlich politiker wirtschafts
und andere interessenvertreter setzen
fremming häufiger ein
kommen wir zurück auf unser beispiel
frau benutzt das wort welle in
verbindung mit flüchtlingen und schafft
damit einen negativen rahmen gut
verpackt durch streaming bis der flucht
vieler menschen vor krieg oder anderen
ursachen eine naturkatastrophe
eine gefahr für die menschen in den
zielländern schauen wir uns ein weiteres
schreib fortan mietenwahnsinn der
begriff säure schreiben dass preise in
deutschland in exorbitante höhen steigen
werden und somit das wohn unbezahlbar
wäre das wort enthält uns allerdings vor
dass es sowohl sozialwohnungen als auch
wohn gelder für sozial benachteiligte
gibt die ein bezahlbares wohnen
ermöglichen
außerdem wird nicht berücksichtigt dass
mietpreise auch von größe und lage der
wohnung abhängen und oftmals erst diese
auswahl entscheidend ist grundsätzlich
ist fremming nicht schlimm wir alles
schaffen einen interpretations raum mit
der wahl unserer worte oft ohne dass wir
das bemerken interessenvertreter setzen
fremming allerdings sehr bewusst
ein um die meinung der menschen zu
beeinflussen deshalb ist es sehr wichtig
dass wir stets hinterfragen dass diese
person mit der auswahl ihrer worte
erreichen wollen
was meint ihr ist fremming einfach nur
ein stilmittel oder es da schon
manipulation schreibt es in die
kommentare